>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IS NOW
ENTERING ITS FOURTH WEEK.
AND NEITHER SIDE HAS MOVED
MUCH.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BEEN ARGUING
FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS THAT
THE UNITED STATES NEEDS A WALL
ON ITS SOUTHERN BORDER.
AGREE WITH HIS POSITIONS OR
NOT, TRUMP HAS EXPLAINED WHY
HE BELIEVES THAT REPEATEDLY
AND IN GREAT DETAIL.
MOST RECENTLY IN A LIVE
ADDRESS TO THE COUNTRY.
DEMOCRATS MEANWHILE ARGUED THE
OPPOSITE.
AMERICA SHOULD NOT HAVE A
BORDER WALL.
THEY HAVE SAID AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS THEY
REALLY HAVEN'T EXPLAINED WHY.
AT VARIOUS TIMES DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS TOLD US THAT WALLS
DON'T WORK.
WALLS ARE RACIST.
WALLS ARE WASTEFUL.
THEY ARE INEFFICIENT.
WALLS ARE EXCESSIVE AND TOO
OLD FASHION.
THEY ARE MEDIEVAL OR ANCIENT
DEPENDING WHO IS READING THE
TALKING POINT AT THE TIME.
SOME OF THE ARGUMENTS ARE
SEMI-REAL.
OTHERS ARE TRANSPARENTLY FAKE.
STILL OTHERS FLATLY CONTRADICT
ONE ANOTHER.
RHETORICALLY THE DEMOCRATIC
CASE AGAINST WALLS HAS BEEN A
MASK FROM THE BEGINNING.
AT ONE POINT HOUSE SPEAKER
NANCY PELOSI TRIED TO BRING
ORDER TO THE CHAOS FLATLY
DECLARING THAT WALLS ARE
IMMORAL.
SHE SAID THAT REPEATEDLY WITH
THE FORCE OF RELIGIOUS EDICT
IN EFFECT IT WAS.
BUT IN THE END THE THEOLOGY OF
IT ALL WAS TOO COMPLEX AND IT
SEEMED TO CONFUSE PEOPLE.
HOW CAN WALLS BE IMMORAL IF A
LOT OF THOSE WHO OPPOSE WALLS
HAVE WALLS AROUND THEIR OWN
HOMES?
THAT WAS A TOUGH CASE TO MAKE.
EVEN FOR A PERSISTENT
FAITH-LEADER LIKE NANCY
PELOSI.
FINALLY PELOSI JUST GAVE UP.
YESTERDAY SHE ACCEPTED THE
INEVITABLY OF A BORDER WALL.
BUT HERE IS THE CATCH.
THE HIDDEN TRAP DOOR IN THESE
SPACE TIME CONTINUUM THAT
PELOSI IS FAMOUS FOR IN
WASHINGTON.
YES, DEMOCRATS NOW SUPPORT A
BORDER WALL.
BUT NO, IT'S NOT THE KIND OF
WALL YOU HAD IN MIND.
THE KIND OF WALL YOU CAN
TOUCH.
OR THE WALL THAT MIGHT KEEP
UNWANTED PEOPLE OUT OF YOUR
COUNTRY.
IT'S INSTEAD A DIGITAL WALL.
A MASSIVE, INVISIBLE EDIFICE
CONSTRUCTED OF VIRTUAL 1s
AND 0s THAT RESIDE IN SOME
AMAZON SERVER FARM SOMEWHERE
IN SUBURBAN VIRGINIA.
IT'S THE WALL OF THE FUTURE,
IN OTHER WORDS.
A WALL THAT GOOGLE MIGHT BUILD
AND PROBABLY WILL.
PELOSI CALLS IT A
TECHNOLOGICAL WALL.
>> House Speaker Pelosi:
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING IS TO
BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE PORTS OF ENTRY.
STRENGTHEN THAT.
SPEND THE MONEY.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS BUT HAVE THE SCANNING
TECHNOLOGY TO SCAN CARS COMING
THROUGH FOR DRUGS, CONTRABAND
OF ANY KIND.
WEAPONS EVEN.
REPAIR THE ROADS, FACILITATE
IMMIGRATION AND TRADE IN THOSE
REGIONS.
THE POSITIVE, SHALL WE SAY,
ALMOST TECHNOLOGICAL WALL THAT
CAN BE BUILT IS WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE!
A TECHNOLOGICAL WALL.
WHY DIDN'T WE THINK OF THAT?
BUT WAIT, YOU SAY.
AREN'T ALL WALLS TECHNOLOGICAL
WALLS?
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE, OF
COURSE;  IS IN THE KIND OF
TECHNOLOGY THEY EMPLOY?
WELL, YES.
BUT BEFORE YOU GET HUNG UP ON
A SEMANTIC POINT BE GRATEFUL
THAT PELOSI IS USING THE "W"
WORD AT ALL.
THERE WAS A TIME NOT LONG AGO
TELLING US A FRIETE OF
LAWNMOWERS WOULD BE ENOUGH TO
SECURE THE BORDER.
>> House Speaker Pelosi:
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHERE A
EXPERIENCE STRUCTURE WILL DO,
OR MOWING THE GRASS SO PEOPLE
CAN'T BE SMUGGLED THROUGH THE
GRASS.
>> Tucker: AT A CERTAIN
POINT YOU BEGIN TO WONDER IF
DEMOCRATS ARE AS SERIOUS AS
THEY SAY THEY ARE ABOUT
WANTING TO SECURE THE BORDER.
MAYBE YOU ASKED YOURSELF THAT
QUESTION.
WELL, WONDER NO MORE.
THEY ARE NOT INTERESTED.
OFFICIALLY.
DEMOCRATS SUPPORT OUR
IMMIGRATION CRISIS.
WHICH THEY WILL BE QUICK TO
REMIND YOU ISN'T ACTUALLY A
CRISIS AT ALL BUT PART OF THE
POEM OF THE BASIS OF THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY.
THE MAIN INTEREST IS
CONTINUING THE STATUS QUO.
THEY WANT TO DO THAT AND MAKE
SURE CERTAIN NO EFFECTIVE
BARRIER IS EVER BUILT ALONG
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
TO ACHIEVE THAT, DEMOCRATS AND
THE FAITHFUL LACKIES IN THE
PRESS WILL SAY ANYTHING,
LITERALLY ANYTHING.
YESTERDAY, TO NAME ONE AMONG
MILLION EXAMPLES DEMOCRAT
KATIE HILL OF CONGRESS,
ACCUSED TRUMP OF TERRORISM FOR
DISAGREE WITH HER.
>> IT'S FRUSTRATING EVERY DAY
TO SEE HOW IRRATIONM HE --
IRRATIONAL HE IS.
WE CAN'T ACCEPT IT ANYMORE.
IT'S POLITICAL TERRORISM.
>> Tucker: TERRORISM?
MAYBE THAT'S NEXT WEEK TALKING
POINT.
CHECK THE SUNDAY SHOWS TO SEE
IF IT MAKES AN APPEARANCE
THERE.
THIS WEEK THE PHRASE WAS
"VANITY PROJECT."
THE WALL, THEY ARE TELLING
YOU, IS SOMEHOW THE
PRESIDENT'S VANITY PROJECT
LIKE REMODELED BASEMENT REC
ROOM OR THE CLINTON
PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY.
SOME CONSULTANT THOUGHT UP THE
LINE AND E-MAILED IT TO PELOSI
AND SCHUMER WHO MADE SURE
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN WASHINGTON
INCLUDED IT IN EVERY PUBLICLY
UTTERED STENSE FOR A PERIOD OF
AT LEAST -- SENTENCE FOR
PERIOD OF 24 HOURS WHICH THEY
WERE HAPPY TO DO BEING ROBOTS.
WATCH.
>> CONSTRUCTION BRIGADE FOR
THE PRESIDENT'S VANITY
PROJECT.
>> IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
REQUIRE OUR BUILDING OF VANITY
PROJECT, CONCRETE WALL.
>> FOR ONE THING THIS IS A
VANITY WALL.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS HOLDING IT
UP AS HIS VANITY PROJECT.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE YATES
HAS A VANITY PROJECT THAT HE
DOESN'T WANT TO GIVE UP.
>> THIS IS NOT ON THE
PRESIDENT'S VANITY PROJECT.
>> THIS ISSUE IS ABOUT A
VANITY PROJECT FOR THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> Tucker: VANITY!
WELL, THAT IS A NEW CONCERN IN
WASHINGTON.
AS IT TURNS OUT VANITY IS THE
MAIN REASON THE LEFT LOVES
MASS IMMIGRATION IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THEY LET MILLIONS OF POOR
PEOPLE IN TO YOUR COUNTRY AT
YOUR EXPENSE.
BUT THEY GET TO FEEL LIKE
HEROES FOR DOING IT.
IT'S REALLY THE EQUIVALENT OF
FORCING A STRANGER TO DUMP HIS
WATER IN THE COLLECTION PLATE
AT GUNPOINT AND TAKING THE TAX